party down party down you're talking
about party now right uh you know ron
donald is
a guy who
i mean
everything every choice he makes it's
all important to him and so
i think it's
uh
played
it's played to be real through the
character that he is
do i make some do i try to make some
comic choices in there some
physicalities or like different things
like
within a scene sure but like
my hope is that it's always
grounded and
real
makes sense was was party then did you
think it was gonna be successful when
you guys were doing it
did you have any idea do you ever know
really
uh
no
i mean i i knew it was a special show i
knew the people that i was working with
were
like talented and special and good
people and there wasn't there was a
an energy that
i liked and i hoped that it would be
successful because
uh
i like being around that
energy and how many seasons did you do a
party down we did two
just two seasons yeah it was more than
that it was for stars uh which nobody
had at the time
it only got a following
like netflix had just started and they
had put out the seasons on netflix but
at that but by that point uh it was
already a
um a sinking ship
but supposedly they're bringing this
back yes
supposedly
well do you know the answer
yeah supposedly
and
what's
what are they going to do supposedly uh
a season another uh like a season for
stars supposedly and how exciting i mean
they were working on a movie at one
point i don't think that's happening
but it's it's uncanny it's just
this doesn't happen a lot a show airs
two seasons
and then they want to bring it back
well i mean that's just that's a rarity
i've been on a lot of shows that last
one season two seasons they don't five
years how long was the rest of
development on
three seasons right what was it four it
was three and then they brought it back
for four times yeah
like i said it's a rarity look i hope
they bring it back i don't i can't oh so
you're not you can't divulge i don't
know i mean i i i know they've always
talked about it and it's a possibility
and you want to do it of course
any chance to get to work with those
guys again is a gift
you know you know how it is you work
with like a lot of people that you know
or people that you enjoy
spending time around and creating with
that's it goes back to what i was saying
about hot american summer as soon as i
realized oh
you know
this is this is special and rare and
but something that i can strive for and
try to
be immersed in as much as possible
that's that's all i try to do i try to
work with people i enjoy and
and whose uh
comic sensibilities i appreciate and
respond to and then
sometimes the stuff is successful
sometimes it's not but ultimately i
think it's
always interesting and good did you some
level did you think what hot american
summer would have been the cult classic
that it's become no but that's another
you know show where like we shot it and
we're like
who we don't care if anybody watches
this we know it's funny
and it was all your friends
it's like you're going to camp with all
your friends that's what we did we
stayed at a camp for uh
you know seven weeks or six weeks and we
all just stayed at at this uh camp uh
during the off season it was great and
you just did what you wanted in in a
sense like you do a take uh did david
just sort of say i mean didn't you
co-write it i did not show all he and
show walter and show walter so when
they're doing these when they're filming
are you
able to
improvise do they want you to stick to a
script they go give me a ken take give
me a big i mean back then it was david's
first movie he was directing a lot of us
was our first movie that we were in and
you know much like any
i mean there wasn't a lot of time to
improvise a lot because it was a short
short schedule and ambitious and um but
yeah of course you know everybody sort
of
tried different things but um the script
you know everybody stuck to the script
at first and tried to honor that when
you watch it now when's the last time
you saw it
i think i watched it with my son who's
14 recently and then he watched the
series and so maybe within the last year
i don't know if i watched the whole
thing what did he think he loved it or
he i think he really liked it i think he
appreciated it
it's just a classic do you just not love
that movie
it really is
so many great characters in there